si l'air que ça me permet d'avoir une
facturation plus conforme à ma
consommation à tous tes photos matic
mans la partie pause s'est passé
simplement avec une prise de rendez vous
on va confirmer que tout était gratuit
jaune et vert est strictement rien à
payer
il est hors de question je la paye donc
là il y aura litige et gérer le dry
tribunaux s'il faut le def fait chez eux
dès que le labo les il ne peut rien
voilà c'est brillant quoi déjà complet y
compris pas mal je trouve s'arrête pas
d'augmenter donc moi j'ai rien demandé
d'avoir ce conteur ou pas
alors laurent méric est arrivée porte
parole des néo 10 ans charles de linky
merci d'être là franchement merci non
parce que je vous le dis ils sont tous
énervés contre vous non mais je vous le
dis donc c'est courageux de venir ce
soir
alors on va on va les écouter après vous
allez pouvoir répondre aux questions
parce que je pense que tous les français
qui nous regardent ce soir attendent vos
réponses
alors on va re résumé la sphère gilles
verdez donc c'est un conteur qui était
gratuit et qui va être payant qu'on nous
a obligés à l'allemagne 4 si on ne
mettait pas monsieur je vous le dit les
yeux dans les yeux j'ai calmé je suis
très calme expliqué déjà alors c'est un
conteur nouveau compteur puis qu'on
oblige les particuliers à mettre parce
qu'on vous dit si vous ne le mettez pas
en ce moment où il ya quelques mois la
plus tard vous devrez payer la pause
donc mettez le maintenant et d'ailleurs
vous êtes obligé de le mettre
parce que si vous ne mettez pas on
pourra pu relever vos compteurs et quand
un agent viendra vous paierez aussi la
visite de l'agent donc on met un
compteur linky monsieur et vous n'avez
plus que ça à nous proposer on est
obligé de prendre linky ckoi linky c'est
un conteur con mais chez vous qui nous
espionne qui nous surveillent qui sait
combien on est à la maison et qui va
nous coûter de l'argent fait vous êtes
tout seul
obligé on va être obligé de rembourser
s'est posé en car nous avait promis que
c'était gratuit
130 euros et vous allez-vous faire de
l'argent sur nous parce que c'est un
emprunt que les contribuables les
usagers vont rembourser avec des taux
d'intérêt qui vous favorisez monsieur je
vous le dis je suis scandalisée par ce
que vous avez fait honnêtement vous avez
tué l'estiment que j'avais pour inédit
c'est pour les fournisseurs d'énergie
je suis un homme a été sérieusement
alors au volant que je peux oui vous
allez répondre à tout le monde après
vous allez voir alors on voulait déjà
lui répondu j'espère remonter le style
vous êtes vraiment oui prestine de tous
nos clients après il est fort gilles
verdez à 35 millions d'autres clients
enfin à lui oui wind sur tous les autres
clients
j'entends gilles les complotistes en
fait ça tu me dis que c'est un conteur
pour nous espionner c'est juste un
compteur pour mieux estimer notre
consommation de déjà première chose
ensuite enfance on est tellement habitué
à rien payé tout est gratuit les étais
tu plaisantes
on avait d'accord l'écouté gratuite
gratuite énormément de services qui sont
gratuits en france je suis désolé vous
devez le savoir l'accès aux soins à
l'école et ses pirates s'est dit qu'on
doit mettre les six mois terminés que
alléché doit mettre la main à la poche
c'est un scandale je suis désolé dias
winner et 830 euros
on vend plier pas nous dit tout et c'est
quelque chose qui relève du public c'est
pas une arnaque l'indien qui êtes des
complotistes à dire qu'on nous vole et
qu'on nous espionnent c'est l'important
je suis désormais acculés les pouvoirs
publics qu'est-ce qui nous ont dit quand
le coup le conteur qui n'inquiète
arrivés et nous ont dit rassurez vous il
faut le mettre parce que vous allez en
plus faire vous des économies d'énergie
et des économies donc financière et donc
ça on va vous le posez chez vous et ce
sera gratuit jusqu'au 10 2010 c'est
gratuit on nous a dit à la base c'était
gratuit là point barre qu'est ce qu'on
apprend c'est que ça la facture totale
ses 5,7 milliards d'euros inédit sa
finance et 5,3 10% sur ses fonds propres
et a été chercher un emprunt auprès de
la banque européenne d'investissement
sauf que cet emprunt c'est pas inédite
qui va le payer
c'est nous qui allons le rembourser et
en plus de ça qu'est ce qu'on apprend
c'est que vous allez en plus faire une
marche dessus une marche de 2 8% ce qui
fait un disque 2 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires que nous allons payer ce
qui est quand même assez dingue
alors que on nous harcèle en nous moi
par exemple la maman pendant longtemps a
refusé parce qu'on l'appelait
régulièrement examen ce moment c est moi
c'était moi quand j'ai regardé mon
contrat je veux garder mon compteur mais
on lui a fait peur au téléphone va
madame vous serez hors la loi vous ne
pouvez pas refuser le compteur linky
absolument et la finma répondre à toutes
vos questions finalement on lui on lui
impose
et une fois qu'on le lui imposer on va
lui on lui dit pas madame maintenant
c'est payant mais je suis désolé pour
moi c'est un scandale
en plus on va se faire dont ils vont se
faire de l'argent sur nous alors laurent
allait répondre
je crois qu'il ya vraiment une question
que les téléspectateurs se pose ce soir
et plus largement tous les français
c'est est-ce que ce compteur va impacter
la facture d'électricité et la réponse
ça c'est non la réponse avec claire
c'est non mais c'est pas ça c'est que
silva gratuit laïb ô combien 130 c 130
euros par an c 130 euros sont
intégralement financée par enée 10
sociétés entreprises de service public
qui a la mission en france d'amener
l'électricité jeu 35 millions de clients
et cette mission dont l'horizon depuis
maintenant plus de 70 ans mais il en
fait et en fait pourquoi est-ce que ce
conteur qu'ils n'impactent pas la
facture d'électricité des clients il n'y
aura pas de hausse de la facture comme
ça estimé sal soleil on sait si c'est
moi c'est la vraie question est la vraie
question si c'est pourquoi un compteur
qui est dans la vraie question c'est ce
que tout le monde dit sur les réseaux je
vous jure
pourquoi il était gratuit et maintenant
il vaut 130 euros il ne vaut pas 130
euros alors elle ne vaut pas ce que c
130 euros que vous considérez cette
année 10 qui les financent simplement
laissez moi juste une minute pour
l'expliquer pas d'accord effectivement
valérie a raison globalement ça coûte
autour de 130 euros par compteur x 35
millions de clients c'est à dire autour
de 5 milliards d'euros commente ses
finances et ses financée par les
économies que nous est né dix sociétés
de services publics
il ya cheminon l'électricité allons
réaliser à partir de 2022 sur nos frais
à nous sur notre fonctionnement sur nos
investissements parce que le réseau sera
de meilleure qualité
nos coûts vont baisser par exemple nous
n'aurons plus à nous déplacer chez vous
pour relever votre compteur ce sont 64
millions de déplacements annuels qui
seront évités on n'aura plus à se
déplacer pour mettre en service
électricité
on vous amène à gérer quelque part il
veuille en faire des économies sur les
21 agréées
vous auriez pu vous ces économies sur
les 20 années qui arrivent vont servir à
rembourser ses 130 euros donc je vous le
dis très clairement d'un million c'est
faux la facture ne va pas y avoir
d'augmentation liées au cannabis et non
demandé il faut vraiment avoir est-ce
que oui ou non parce que je rappelle on
parle on s'est quand même le ministre de
l'industrie à l'époque c'est eric besson
a utilisé l'argument de la gratuité pour
que tout le monde
marie paule installe chez soi la
question c'est est ce que oui ou non on
va nous retirer 130 euros un moment
donné pour payer ce compteur c'est ça la
crise économique la réponse de notre
question monsieur ces noms précis arrêts
formidables vous retirez 133 on a là
rien pas pourquoi vous avez été gérée 5
milliards alors c'est 5 milliards
d'années emprunter de l'argent si c'est
pas pour nous prendrons le redis c'est 5
milliards
il a fallu entre 2016 et fin 2021
d'accord installé 35 millions de
compteurs c'est les pouvoirs méric
alors oui certes mais si j'ai tenté un
jeu bien là et c'est même le président
de ses 8 points capitaux qui m'a dit mon
frère où le compteur a un impact sur la
facture à la campagne chez moi c'est un
cauchemar
oui le futur mais j'aimais aussi cela la
consommation est calculé sur les avant
c'était son la moyenne
maintenant c'est sûr les heures pleines
oui non cela changera votre contraignent
à votre feuille cissé font c'est faux
vous savez aujourd'hui au jour on parle
là il ya sur les 35 millions de
compteurs prévu 32 ont été installés et
les parements oui et laxatifs ayant
mesure la satisfaction de nos clients
après la pause aujourd'hui nous avons un
taux de satisfaction de 90 % à paris
mais quand c'est grave et on et sa
fausse laurent blanc s'est coupée lors
un vrai sujet de roland ce complément de
super mais c'est vrai qu'elle a raison
ce sondage
il a été réalisé à ce grave quand on a
dit aux gens je vous aime gratuite aux
gens on va arriver à vous mettre un truc
ça va at oui bah moi je suis content
allez payer le mettais en plusieurs même
si vous voulez bien sûr mais quand on
dit que c'est 30 ans 230 euros
là je pense que le sondage si vous leur
faites pour être plus compliqué jradi
mom harceler pour l'installer en disant
en gros vous payer sans vous allez payer
92 donc pourquoi pas et si vous le
faites pas ça va pas vous allez payer
moins or vous vous dites finalement vous
payer sans madame aujourd'hui mais vous
allez continuer à payer 100 or soit
disant le linky c'est pour faire des
économies d'énergie
donc en fait si je paye la même chose ça
veut dire que quelque part je paye alors
il ya deux sujets merci de cette
question parce qu'elle est vraiment
intéressante c'est là où messi est ce
que ça va est-ce que
une truffe au tennis mais sinon dans la
paix à l'est la première question est ce
que ça va peser sur ma facture
l'installation du compteur la réponse
est le caire allait net c'est non la
deux le deuxième sujet que vous évoquez
c est ce qu avec ce compteur je vais
pouvoir faire des économies sur ma
facture
la réponse c'est oui parce que grâce à
ce qu'on tient pas de nouvelles vont en
fait oui exactement tiens je vous montre
un truc là c'est l'application et 10 à
mes côtés mais tous les fournisseurs
d'électricité ont eu la même honte une
application peut nous rend son
application
[Applaudissements]
c'est un kit est né dix vous venez chez
nous regardez ça dépend mais l'argent
alors ça c'est mon espace client perso
on voit ma consommation d'hier et on
voit aussi que par exemple d'une journée
sur l'autre j'ai consommé 20 8% de moins
que la veille et je peux le faire par
semaine je peux le faire par moi je peux
le faire par saison à diminuer un
krombach c'est quoi ça c'est un espace
qui me permette c'est vraiment ce que je
consomme au jour le jour et en faisant à
faisant ça bien je peux mieux maîtriser
ma consommation et je peux donc si je le
souhaite faire réduire ma facture c'est
moi qui l'ait kg chacun le discours
ambitieux toulon refusait la loire
mairie c'est l'ademe bernard vu passer
même si l' agence de la transition
écologique ben laden a fait une étude
qui montre que on peut gagner jusqu'à 10
% sa nature à grasse et au compteur
juste 530 euros il sort de bala est ce
qu'à un moment pas nous faire et on va
nous prélever sans trembler oui nous
menons
sinon non mais alors histoire de nous
entretuer marsoui santé ils sont
financés je vous le redis c'est
réunissait avec les économies que nous
est né dix nous allons réaliser pas
manger du couquet 50 euros maintenant
aujourd'hui focalisée sur les 130 euros
c'est que ça va nous coûter beaucoup
plus cher en consommation je n'irai plus
cher dix en temps réel attends je vais
vous dire donner plus fine toutes ces
expressions a eu sa dose est plus fine
en temps réel pour mieux maîtriser la
consommation
ouais dans le cul oui
[Applaudissements]
une salle à quoi s'est jamais trompé
c'est parce qu'il a une tête sabbatique
là oui c'est vrai qu'il est sympa c'est
déjà ça c'est déjà envoyé le bon gars
mais pas de l'émission il a cinquante
propositions mais mon compteur linky est
une merde chez moi d'ailleurs floues
donnent l'adresse mais les patrons de
ces médias vous évoquiez les factures
des usagers augmente vous savez très
bien tout le monde à des augmentations
moi j'arrête pas de nous appeler pour
comprendre que vous êtes incapable de
m'expliquer parce que les gens ceux qui
travaillent pour vous ne comprennent pas
pourquoi mais c'est le facture augmenter
monsieur monsieur ça c'est parce que
vous commencez gilles ce que vous êtes
en train de dire à nos téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoignent anna très nombreux
qui nous rejoindra à 29,53 j'vous l'dit
l'histoire c'est cette histoire de
compteurs linky est censé être gratuit
oui et aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'il va
falloir compter entre autres charles
gautier fabrication et pose compris
comment on va payer ses 130 euros
générés et ben parce que en fait ce
compteur linky vous allez vous arrangez
pour qu'il fasse augmenter notre
consommation votre schéma il est gentil
mais il est bidon
demandez aux français les gens crèvent
las de payer de l'électricité assure les
manettes tellement c'est cher donc c'est
pas possible monsieur et vous à les
répercuter sur chaque facture pendant
plusieurs mois
vous allez diviser 130 euros par dix ou
quinze c'est ça pour nous faire des
petites augmentations et on les dérange
pas sur les 15 années vous harris et
énonce trois mois offert moi je fais je
comprends pas le ton est agressif que
vous employez parce que c'est un sujet
que c'est sérieux c'est bien simple
maman excusez moi d'accord ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que vous savez ils
disent nous nous sommation nous sommes
30 38 salariés de service public notre
engagement c'est de faire en sorte que
tous les jours h 24 vous ayez donne
électricité chez vous c'est le produit
de service public qui a le meilleur taux
de deux de nos coupure c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui nous tient à coeur
on met en place tout un réseau 1 million
400 mille kilomètres de lignes
électriques d'accord au bout duquel il
ya des compteurs d'électricité parce
qu'il faut bien que vous soyez facture
et c'est normal il ya un comptage
d'accord mais bon c'est notre métier est
il que voulez-vous que je vous dise
vous montez un espèce de complot là bas
de six ans un projet que je suis un
génial vous savez qu'on n'a pas prononcé
ce soir dont gilles sylvain willot l'on
gagne à moi quoi bien vous qu'on n'a pas
prononcé ce soir c'est celui de
transition écologique mais ce quartier
là alors sa transition écologique c'est
une en audience est catastrophé mais je
vous en dirai pas présent pas ça pour le
plaisir sur la tête de ma mère de la
chanteuse engagée
je t'ai régalé j'ai tout dit sur toi si
tu veux je te le donne et 130 battus et
human le dit pas trop dit socalled
histoire de rendre comme un service non
mais je t'adore non je vous dis plus
raisonnable c'est même je t'aime
beaucoup nous tous a donc tout ça donc
s'il te plaît en tout cas sa vie pour
ceux que ça intéresse c'est un outil
formidable pour réussir sa transition
écologique en tout cas y contribuer
laurent le développement des intérêts
généraux de la bhl d'où le développement
des réserves
c'est vraiment essentiel d'où il sort
ses sweats 60
je le supplie à judy wade wilson messin
dix mois d'août en supplie comment ils
ont su alors nous on a sorti sans trop
tôt je dis moi juste où il s'en moque et
comment attendait comment vous faites
pour acheter de maison
comment font les français pour acheter
une maison voilà on en prend un c'est
assez simple on emprunte et on rembourse
après ouais on gagne ça à faire et à
dire qu'on a eu on a eu la mission de
remplacer les compteurs 35 millions de
compteurs depuis 2016 jusqu'à 2020
évidemment nous avons financé cet
investissement en partie par de
l'emprunt et après que nous l'ayons fait
mais on nous a embrassé à rembourser
jalons ramené à 0 77 voilà comment est
ce que nous faisons pour rembourser pour
rembourser cet investissement que nous
avons emprunté nous allons faire des
économies sur nos frais de
fonctionnement nous allons faire des
économies sur le réseau le rendre plus
performant pour qu'ils soient nous
meilleure qualité les ensembles de ses
économies sur les 20 années qui arrivent
vont permettre pourquoi notre jour en
valeur lolo je t'en supplie pourquoi
inédit ce fait rembourser en france et
un crédit avec un taux d'intérêt de 4
points 6 alors que vous avez employé à 0
salariale et nima forte en écales a dit
2.8 c 3.8 merci ben on verra votre
salaire vous avez
milhas alors alors dit je comprends
votre islam et lui il faut travailler
chez eux avec question puisque la
lumière vous vous appuierez c'est une
entreprise dont les fonctionnant jl-c du
service public c'est pas quelqu'un qui
nous pose des machines à café pour nous
arnaquer au bout il faut expliquer les
gens qui les choses aient besoin bien tu
peux te poser ton compteur il a un
salaire
le compteur il un prix qu'il faut des
réponses et un support carrément
libéralisation courageuse et c'est une
entreprise d'accord si c'était pas à en
se moquant des gens aux services publics
mariton m'appelle mais il ya des gens
qui travaillent là-bas fois je suis gêné
c'est parler bien sûr on va les payer
il ya problème vous allez payer tout ce
qu on va les payer mais quand on
m'appelle moi pour me dire mettez votre
compteur linky maintenant sinon vous
allez payer moi je compte sur toi qui
est au taquet on au confinement je dis
bien tout de suite frein au jeu là
j'attends je te regarde par la fenêtre
s'est ouvert bien rentrer ses d'urgence
et dans la facture des gens à la fin du
mois lorsque bon vous êtes gentils vous
êtes venus ça faisait qu'il a acheté
mais ça veut dire que si tu me proposes
un truc moi tu me force pas je suis
d'accord si tu commences à me vendre un
truc et tu mens et c'est là que c'est
pas bon parce que ça les sages tunis 330
euros
ça devient un impôt qu'en attendez je
finis vie de fait quand on sait que
linky ce sa collecte des données
certaines données normalement c'est vous
qui devrait nous donner de l'argent et
quand vous dites comme les écrits comme
atlas a donné tous les gentils non
monsieur il nous dit ça va ça va nous
permettre de faire des économies en
faire un fonds de fonctionnement
justement fait nous baisser la facture
l'électricité je parle pas de tout le
reste parce que vous allez avoir les
sens les cigarettes tout ça j'en parle
pas le dentiste effet les pages blanches
à leurs guerres de l'eau l'électricité
le gaz elle fait partie du budget de la
famille si à partir du moment vous vous
n'êtes pas en excès pour moi c'est une
forme de malhonnêteté de me dire c'est
gratuit derrière je parle et je termine
sur les 1 milliards 7 à 10,1 milliards 7
pourquoi vous nous prenez un milliard
sept on est déjà en a déjà pas les sas
écarté comme ça pour encore un carton
encore fumant
c'est violent mais c'est la réalité une
belle image à l'aller
je vais donner un autre exemple il
parlait de transition dit rien contre ce
monsieur ne dit pas très de transition
ça tu laisses tomber son exemption gaga
on avait les noms de rides et on a payé
des vignettes critiqué laurent laurent
que ça nous répondait à cette précieuse
gentiment lagarde s'il vous plaît on
leur répond laurent est venu facilement
vous avez de l'argent vous pouvez pas ce
monsieur j'ai vu ce que disait valéry
mézague à vous la connaissez je vous
regarde régulièrement quand même énorme
si sympa et comment certaines simplement
ce mécanisme financier qui a été décrit
dans des papiers qui sont parues
aujourd'hui il a été conçu par ce qu'on
appelle la commission de régulation de
l'énergie c'est à dire c'est l'autorité
qui en france réguler le marché
d'énergie sous l'égide de laquelle nous
sommes
ça et c'est elle qui ensuite a proposé
ce mécanisme il ya déjà quelques années
c'était au tour de 2011 2012
ce mécanisme là il a été validé par les
pouvoirs publics dans les gouvernements
par l'assemblée nationale et le sénat le
législateur tout cela a fait l'objet de
validation à de multiples niveaux et
c'est ce mécanisme que vous décrivez
aujourd'hui en allemand qui maman qu'il
faut qu'il faut juger non pas au regard
de ce que la presse écrit aujourd'hui ch
à monsieur mais qu'il faut juger sur
l'ensemble de la durée des programmes
qui démarrent à partir de 2012 qui
commencent à être mises en place un 2016
qui s'achève un 2021 et dans le
remboursement va s'achever et en 2004 en
baisse des vocations je vous regardez
les choses mais sur la durée
je compte sur vous non seulement ma mais
je veux être très clair non seulement
pour ne vous facture absolument rien
pour ce compteur linky non plus il vous
permet parce que il vous plaît de faire
des économies en maîtrisant votre
consommation
en changeant de fournisseur fascinant
c'est 15 euros supplémentaires sur la
facture voilà mais non mais il faut
aussi si vous lisez le papier et les
papiers a fait ses 130 euros / c'est un
raccourci qui n'a aucune valeur
nissan à l'euro revienne valeurs je vous
le redis accès sera le nombre d'heures
passées sur la facture mal est il normal
qu'un impact sur la facture c'est clair
c'est net c'est précis et en plus c'est
un outil qu'est franchement assez
formidable qui est moderne oblige est le
premier objet nolan on est en avance sur
un outil comme ça ça nous mais je le
seul à vraiment le merci je connais la
transition du casque la remercier on l'a
on va dire au revoir à l'europe qu'à
raison alors et c'est laurent lui
[Rires]
en tant qu'usagers pour moi je sais tu
m'en payer mais pour un truc que j'ai
voulu pas pour un truc comme a osé ça on
a épousé mais plusieurs membres vraiment
champions à rien on a tous d après vous
avez raison dans la consommation je suis
désolé avant les gens disaient photo
faut faire une lessive tous à la nuit on
le faisait ça saute et pas avec un
compteur linky je vous jure que plus de
la moitié des habitations et des trucs
qui sortent la nuit ce qui les oblige à
prendre un abonnement plus cher verser
ses dents mais leur combat mène
aujourd'hui à 32 millions comme la
catégorie de planteurs en france 32
millions de consommateurs qui utilisent
le conteur qui tue ses services
je vous garantis que ce que vous dites
sans rompre et ça n'arrive pas à la
moitié des consommateurs c'est marginal
et l'essentiel c'est de noter que grâce
à ce compteur on a un service public
moderne qui permet à tous les français
de maîtriser leur consommation elle
marche mais soyons fiers de ça de coller
on a un service public supports modernes
soyons aux enchères collective mais moi
je trouve que la libérale c'est une
bonne nouvelle si la chaire immersif